we are just days now into the new school
year and parents are already getting
emails about confirmed copic 19 cases
right now 50 students from coral academy
windmill campus are being quarantined
allowing for two positive cases that
happened this week kate houston spoke to
parents some say they didn't expect so
many cases so soon
there's no best case scenario and i
think we're all doing the best we can
motu laura's son attends coral academy
windmill campus and understands the
precautions being taken the variant is
very like serious and i agree with it
only because
like i would rather not get people sick
the windmill campus is for grades five
through seven with many students not
meeting the minimum age to get the covet
vaccine while more than four dozen
students have been quarantined i'm told
no staff were sent home why open the
schools if it's still going to happen
you know why even have masks on if it's
still going to happen gary bay does not
agree with the regulations saying it
puts families in a difficult position
financially affecting us
mentally affecting us you know we don't
know what the prolonged consequences of
the kids wearing the masks are going to
be coral academy is not the only school
dealing with this clark county school
district parents tell me they've also
received emails confirming positive
covet 19 cases according to the ccsd
covid 19 dashboard there have been 47
confirmed cases this week after the
first day i got it i'm like oh my gosh
like here we go like this is a nightmare
while parents like christina expected
some cases this is making her reconsider
in-person learning it's scary honestly
it's like we kind of want the kids to go
back we feel like they need that you
know
the social stuff with their friends and
all that type of stuff but
i almost rather them stay home and be
safe then you know to take that chance
kate houston 8 news now
parents will get a personal call from
ccsd if their child has come into
contact with a positive case coral
academy is currently working with the
southern nevada health district on
contact tracing as well as sanitation